الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون يقف
منفردا في وجه اوروبا مواقفه المتفردته
فيما يخص الحرب في اوكرانيا تثير حفيظه
الدول الاتحاد فراغم الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا ورفض الحرب يتفهم ماكرون مخاوف
روسيا من اصول حلف الناتو لحدودها الغربيه
ونشر اسلحته هناك ولتهدئه تلك المخاوف
والمره الثانيه خلال شهر يطالب ماكرون
بمنح روسيا ضمانات امنيه في حال جرت
مفاوضات السلام لانهاء الحربي في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من يلوموني على التفكير في مثل هذا
الموضوع فليشرح لي ما الذي يقترحه
الرئيس الفرنسي لم يكتفي بهذا بل حذر من
ان رفض منح ضمانات لروسيا قد يشعل حربا
شامله في القاره باكملها تصريحات اثاره
انتقادات علنيه ومبطنه للرئيس الفرنسي ليس
من كيف وحدها بل من قاده في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ذهب بعضهم الاتهام باريس بتسامح
مع مصر
[موسيقى]
يكون من خلال تقديم ضمانات امنيه
لاوكرانيا اما بالنسبه لروسيا سنتحدث عنها
لاحقا
في المره الاولى وبعد تعرض الرئيس الفرنسي
الى هجمات زملائه من قاده اوروبا دافعه
حينها قصر الاليزا عن الرئيس بان تصريحات
مكرون حول منح روسيا ضمانات امنيه اخرجت
من سياقها لكن في المره الثانيه الرئيس
الفرنسي دافع عن نفسه قبل ان ينتهي من
تصريحاته لاعلامه المحلي بحثه لزعماء
اوروبا على شرح البديل الذي يقترحونه
للمحادثات النهائيه مع الكرم قبل ان تشمل
نيران الحرب شرق اوروبا القاره باكملها
حنان المصري العربي
[موسيقى]